you know sometimes certain organizations
get large enough that they become
enamored with themselves arrogant it can
happen it really can it could happen to
organizations at almost any size but it
certainly happens with some of the big
companies because they get large enough
that they really think they control the
world Apple Amazon Google examples of
that sometimes they get arrogant here's
one visa visa takes a war on cash to the
restaurants visa has a new offer for
small merchants this according to this
article to take thousands of dollars
from the card giant to upgrade their
upgrade their payment technology and in
return the business must stop accepting
cash the company unveiled the initiative
on Wednesday is part of a broader effort
to steer Americans away from using
old-fashioned paper money Visa says is
planning to give $10,000 apiece for up
to 50 restaurants and food vendors to
pay for their technology and marketing
costs as long as the businesses pledge
to start what visa executive Jack four
still calls a journey to cashless or in
a war with cash the CEO says consumers
at those stores would be able to pay for
goods or services only with a debit or
credit card or with their cell phone in
exchange Visa is offering to pay for
upgrades to merchants technology at the
checkout line so that they can accept
contactless payments like Apple pay the
$10,000 and Senate can also help cover
some of the merchants marketing expenses
visas long considered cash one of its
biggest competitors and has been taking
steps to quote chip away at it no pun
intended
getting rid of cash is a priority for
visa chief executive officer al Kelly
who took over late last year especially
as cash and check transactions continue
to global globally
see here's the problem here's really
ready for this here's the deal cards
have made a dent in the US
but cash remains the most widely used
form of payment among Americans
accounting for 32% of all consumer
transactions okay so you own a
restaurant and visa waddles in the door
fat sassy and says you want to give up a
third of your customers if you'll give
up a third of your customers we'll give
you some free technology that in two
years to three years will be obsolete
because you know how long those payment
things work right I mean they're it's
it's such a computer when you get out of
the box it's already obsolete you know
how fast you have to turn over payment
systems well we have them so I'll just
tell you they don't last because the
technology shifts and the hardware wears
and changes and the processes change and
everything else and so you might get
four years out of it but are you going
to give up a third of your customers for
$10,000 a third of your customers
forever that's that's kind of stupid I
mean you know anybody that's running a
business usually can pass the sixth
grade math test and they listen if a
third of your customers for the rest of
your life the rest of the time your
business is open is only worth $10,000
you probably need another business your
business is sucking pretty bad I mean
over three years that's $3,000 a year I
mean this is nothing right over ten
years it's a thousand dollars here right
I mean it's nothing
so for visa to think they can pull this
off assumes that you business people and
these are primarily small business
people that they would be aiming at with
this because I can promise you the
Costco's and Sam's and the Walmarts of
the world are not going to make this
trend the Home Depot's the Lowe's
they're not going to make this
transition they understand what their
customer cash customer looks like at
their cash register they know exactly
who and she and she is and they know
exactly in each store what they amount
to
so there's not any chance they're taking
up on this offer so they're aiming in a
mom-and-pop or a little restaurant and
they're trying to give you $10,000 worth
of stuff upfront to bribe you into the
land of stupidity and giving up a third
of your customers that's arrogance
that's corporate arrogance on steroids
and so on I predict that the small
business owners in America are smarter
than this I predict that this little
program of the arrogant giant visa will
be a colossal failure that's my
prediction I also predict that as long
as I am Alive that this business called
the Ramsey solutions of business we'll
accept cash and we will not accept
American Express we never have can't
stand those people I'm a hillbilly
I'm carry grudges we were going broke 30
years ago American Express called my
wife and asked her why she'd stay with a
man that wouldn't pay his bills she
called me crying at the office saying
why would I stay with the bed they
wouldn't pay his bills I was thinking
the same thing I was ready to go to
Jacksonville Florida the collection
center of American Express whipped some
buddies but that's how rednecks do this
stuff right and I didn't but you know 30
years ago I still remember it
and we still never done any business
with American Express so for me they're
not in here you don't take American
Express new take cash and we take Visa
debit cards on our site in our store and
at our live events got those little
squares swipey thingies and they work
just perfect everything is easy by the
way they're not $10,000 people hello you
know get you a little iPad stick a
square in it it's not a big deal not a
lot to this and you don't need to worry
about a $10,000 thing from visa so yeah
so al Kelly is the CEO of visa this week
oh he took over late last year there it
is yeah because they changed CEOs over
there like underwear so I didn't know
and I suspect this one buying or last
either because it comes up with stupid
stuff like
so it's a good idea for a visa to get
how to get people by the cash business I
mean makes sense but there's just
old-fashioned people like me to still
like to touch their money and see it and
carry you know oh you know I always have
my regular emergency fund but for those
of you don't know if you're redneck you
always have to have another three
hundred dollars stuck somewhere three
100's touch somewhere in the corner of
some wallet that's your redneck
emergency fund
okay so tires flat on the car and some
idiot only takes Visa yeah you got to
have a plan right so this is how it
works I am thinking that visas war on
cash will probably a little continue but
I don't suspect it would see much
success because I think that small
business restaurant owners across
America are way too smart to trade a
third of their customers for ten grand
it's on the same article on it didn't
take a lot of research figure out how
bad an idea this is this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh